colas held in germany like a whole
myth debriefing online and live it's
light saturday and we start again and a
clijsters that i ask it's in these
play with the polish harry cover of
resilience planes in europe a
commission will have paul's remarks by
distorting  fire extension nagoshi
july jean cindy talks about janis
bassing 18 years old at best
you need the equation sum says polish
recovery and planes azzoun in the ranking
this weekend release date we are
efficient we reason about this topic
so christian via caf  impression
yes hello I want to bounce back on this
little sentence that tells me we are trying
to complete the evaluation of what
can be done the request for
an extension period of the two extensions and
very first on August
1 on August 1 we were born on July 29 so
does this
little sentence mean that they were
preparing us for a new extension
which could be for a month is
that a month is it possible  to be
two months it was a
recurring question but since you must have
the answer this is my first question
and I take advantage of it because the feeling
that begins to show through
the examination of Poland of the
Polish and Hungarian recovery plans
it is that in fact for the moment we are
in a situation of impasse the
blockages that we wonder at the start of the school year
if we will be able to give a
green light to these two plans if we do not risk
rather because  it does not move at all
to be obliged to block them and therefore
I would like to know if the committee
you are examining this
option which would be a blocking the
previous ones the consequences
the risks of a blocking of the two plans
recovery thank you clear thank you now
the deadline for the plans to come it's
the first high so but no ca
n't speculate that's what can
pass we are evaluating with
seven hours delay but hey that yes so
i just want to add christian so
com  me you probably also
heard so at the
press conference so last monday by
executive vice president dombrowski and
he was very clear he said it's
possible heart we will need
more time to finalize our  our
assessment and that to date there has not
yet been a formal request
from the commission for a
hawks extension and that is all I can
tell you on this subject at the moment thank you there
is  others the question on the plans
take and I mentioned versini in saint
mandrier chile yes hello I
made you an offer to hungary to
relax in front of an additional delay
for the examination of
its recovery I would like to do if
hungary has us  answered i would like to
know this question i have already asked
18 times what if hungary
does not answer or
let's answer mans please answer me
so tell you about hungary or
poland took to ok thank you  for your
question virginia n  we in relation to
hungary so in light of a recent
exchange we had with the and
the hungarian authorities
the commission is therefore hungary we are
working constructively with a
view to concluding the assessment by the
end of  here at the end of september and virginia
killing question disappointed said yes so does that
mean what does that mean that hungary has
accepted the extension of the
review deadline and not until the end of august
but until the end of september
that's what  you're telling me
it was mag is ok so
what I want so I can specify
more
so indeed following an
exchange of letters the
evaluation period was extended and so
we did the  commission asked for an
extension of the deadline and hungary did
not oppose it and reacted
constructively
thank you to the east i think that
clarifies the situation for hungary and
for poland with the recovery plan a few
years ago  other questions about the
long rice dish  answers on strike and
polish here no adequacy say it all
[Music]
i admire a portfolio tommaso and zurich
yes hello thank you for giving me apart from
this man this be in question about
taking raises from italy and i
would like to know if the
pre-financing disbursement is scheduled tomorrow at the
earliest next week
thank you
no so there I can tell him effect everything
is what balazs wants to answer no so
what I can confirm to you today
is that indeed the first
pre-payments  final and funding
without planned at the beginning of August
now I cannot give you
more details in relation to the
different member states in question and
their particular situation but therefore
we the commission is doing everything in our
what is in our possible to
really speed up this this process the
more possible I would like to remind you
that according to the regulations
after spoonful prick and an agreement that
was concluded on the financing so
an acc  ord as soon as there is an agreement on
a financing agreement a loan agreement
with the member state in question the
regulation provides that the commission has 60
days to disburse the money but therefore
the commission has done everything to speed up
this procedure  and and aims to
ensure that the money is transferred
within days within a two
day period and therefore not a
two month period
thank you thank you thank you thank you
tommaso are there any further questions for
eastbound  today
yes yes thank you philippe rené newspaper in the
evening about the belgian recovery plan for
belgium which was approved already
several weeks ago I think I think
I saw that there on the Walloon side where
floods took place how like we
we know this, we hope to see a little bit
modulate over time the implementation
of certain projects that are part of
this plan and which had been approved, so
you will know if there are indeed
exchanges with the commission on this subject and
therefore possibly the response of the
commission to possible requests
thank you for your question
christian therefore to the knowledge of the
commission to date the
Belgian authorities have not yet indicated that it
was necessary to modify the
timetable or to adapt the  belgian plan
for recovery and resilience
but it is clear that the commission is
fully prepared to discuss with the
belgian authorities any difficulties
caused by this serious situation
i can also tell you that there is an
ongoing dialogue which is  planned between
the commission and all the member states,
including the Belgian authorities, in order to
really monitor the implementation
of
the plan over the next six
years and this process will
also allow us to identify any delays
or any difficulties  and this will
contribute to finding
mutually agreed solutions to the problems
identified
thank you we all have the question today
on the recovery plans for the  different
countries no I have in question in the
chat online keep your hand up it's
only on these topics there to
pour it on this topic there also our topic
30 40
their acts are the fait accompli
laurent
write is a meteor  exactly is it do
you do things of these young people racing in
a conical shape and 25 cents at t1 and
[Music]
direct with the long ones like in the
middle of the weekend by the sheet to October 2, 2010
exact deadline
[Music]
it's at  microphone like everything situation
greenlight like planets comets
exact of what refuses this week we
will have that i just dance
know you
don't like this kind of questions and not
answered the first time the echoes
i have are that neither poland nor
hungary the background of movements at the
moment that they can give the
commission the possibility of valid  r
in two recovery plans that the
feeling is today the
commission playing in the summer break
but in september var and from the moment
of decisions
that moment of decision it will be is what
you will be able to  tell these two
countries that the recovery plan does
not correspond to the criteria which have
been immense and you are going to refuse
them which would mean that the European Union is
going to enter a
major crisis which risks causing
considerable damage
I would like to know  if you're ready for that
I say if you work on it I
know you're going to freak out it's
natural it's part of the game but I
tell you the echoes that I have
today make me doubt make me
fear rather a  big tension a
big crisis at the start of the school year
I would like to know if you are ready for
it that's all in 1990 we had asked the same
question to your alter egos at the
giresse tribune that the danes risk
refusing maastricht we had been sent to
graze
they said no and we found ourselves
in a crisis so here I am taking the
lead
I am saying it officially
are you ready to take on a major crisis at the commission
do you have commissioners
who will work  the summer to
avoid this problem at the start of the school year
thank you thank you christian doors in
intervention I think that we have already
answered invariants added we are in the
process of evaluating the plans little nose in
greece and therefore we do not have the others and
d'hellemmes element added at this stage
we are evaluating it and we will
decide in the next few months we have
already spoken within the deadline and we can
not add other elements to our
answer for the moment
thank you
moritz  single so chic sober it evokes
a back to you and me if you can is a
very serious question and a resilience
place maria then good day mario stand up
for free belgium
thank you very much sorry I'll try my
luck again because I still haven't
therefore understood  t given that
the independence of the judiciary is part
of the specific content recommendation
is it possible to give the
green light to the recovery plan, for example
to give if problems like those
we are currently encountering in terms
of independence  of justice
I am thinking in particular of the
constitutional court are not resolved
there are no hypothetical questions cc
it is a question of cause and effect
thank you for your question so I can only
confirm what I have already said so this
what we were doing is
really to make sure to complete
our assessment of the
Polish recovery and resilience plan one of the criteria
that we have to assess
is the criterion which provides that a
recovery plan must  contribute to meeting the
challenges that are set out in the
country-specific recommendations or a
significant part of it as has already been
indicated several times cannot
comment on the details of the
negotiations that are ongoing  s
that's what we did and what
we're doing for all the member states
thank you keep your hand on them just
that's the question it's still this set
subject after we'll try to change
subject but i see that catherine
katalin of technique a problem in
decent conditions quickly as so
specific recommendations
the ordering of things and even
maybe your sons the scottish of our
[Music]
common
katalin worrack of the continent
and the  documentary by cameron crowe
in squats and in hd plane contributed
racing holezcyc 9 x top 7
when i arrived here with benichou
micheline de chat you will give winner
fenaille or dispose in 2 min m
we've got origins and unleashed yes to
return to the  plans you have already
proven precisely this issue of
country recommendations
perhaps you can give us telling
examples for france which
country recommendations
france is following in its
recovery plan prime it n  I am not following the
country recommendation to reform the
pension system which was
nevertheless one of the important things that we have been
asking for for years because in
fact it is not at all clear
how you decide that such a
country recommendation is  important according to
such a country so it would be good to give
us concrete examples to show us that
in countries that are less controversial
really they have followed
country recommendations important
thank you what is also important to
note is that this is one of the criteria where
it is necessary  having an a so that means that
the plan must really everything with saint
must really meet this criterion there
but therefore for concrete examples I
propose that you call
me after after help me thank you thank you we will look at that
we can buy  all two elements
after the debriefing in the afternoon
I think he does not have three
questions are his subjects pending room
and weighs by online so we can open
the other questions  I'm going to take into
question what was written in the chat
before thank you it was for me so it's
competition mario newman do you have a
comment on the negotiations between
the French government and the
European commission concerning
sdf so what can I say c  is that the
commission is in contact with the
French authorities on the reform
of regulated access to nuclear energy
and on hydroelectric concessions
as this is an ongoing debate we
have no further comment  on on on
saha has me firmly
we are in contact so when there must
be contact with the French authorities
thank you I see a lot of me
removing myself sorry I have to ask if there are other
competition questions
to close my competition chapter
she has  say no
and emi as we say modestly in the
freezer I don't have time to test
if you still had discussions
with the French government
or if they are betting on its
nuclear energy reform  e the
hydraulic concessions etc had put the subject in the
refrigerator and that we no longer talked about it
I had until an indefinite period
and that we were no longer discussing the edf subject there
as I said we are still in contact
with  the authorities a French
continued to be in contact with thank you I
think we have no
competition questions today so I will
take and other global questions
but bad luck about about the
following negotiations in good
shape he  there will be no cameron is this
a 15-3 frame of this game
possibility on consecutive eric chance
to be a shape and march 6 at 9 p.m. amateur
maclean's coming between jude atom z500
maria yes thank you very much it's not  it's
a question about the migration which i
don't know if you prefer me to wait
or if i can go i think we
can go because i see request
had already started every payment
imagine this topic as long as great
thank you so
i actually hear that  the greek minister drew
the committee's attention yesterday to the
fact that turkey continued to
refuse to accept actually returning
migrants to me from the
greek islands under the agreement between the
european union and  turkey I wanted to
know
here is where is how
do you intend to resolve this situation
and the related question is here are
you still thinking that this
is the answer to the situation of
migrants on the  Greek islands or if
you are looking for other solutions
thank you thank you marriage I think that
d'albert is connected with us
completely thank you marriage I can perhaps
start by confirming that indeed
the commission has received a letter
from the  minister nor to the crisis in
which the minister informs the
committee that the Turkish authorities
have still not accepted the return of
all those people who are not that
they are not eligible for
international protection d is that  the
minister would appreciate
the commission's assistance in particular
through contacts with the
turkish authorities to stress the need
to fully implement the
declaration and turkey the commission
is obviously fully
aware of the challenges
facing the  greek authorities and continue
to support all efforts to ensure that
returns from y to turkey resume
as it should be
under the eu turkey statement
then on your broader question
regarding the situation on the y
obviously the implementation  full text
of the culture declaration, which remains
a priority for us, having
said that, it
is also recalled that the committee is
making a great deal of effort to
provide solutions to the situation on the
Greek islands in a much
broader way, and on this perhaps I will
spare you  the full catalog of
measures the commission is taking we
have published a lot of press material
l  above, but I think it is
important to recall in particular
the existence of the joint task force
between the commission and
greece, which is working on, in particular, the
new centers on the
Greek islands on their rapid reconstruction in
order to avoid a  new a new
dance winter or under tents in
lesbos and in order to provide concrete solutions
to others there, moreover, our
efforts have already borne much
fruit and the congestion, in particular on
the arrival on the stalls of the number of
residences there would have been  so in the
centers on referral has decreased enormously over the
past year
so we continue to monitor the
situation very closely even without committing
alongside the Greek authorities
to improve the situation to
respond to the challenges that are
present thank you very much adalbert also
for the  elements a nice shot
you gave us
are there any other
migration questions i know jack has he has two
different questions  if it is
really daring but for the moment we are
on the theme of migration and if
in the room before sorry dancing when
there is a need I think yes
thank you very much I wanted to know
do you have figures on the
reduction of large  decrease in
congestion on the islands and just
in fact I can hear that the objective
is still to apply the agreement
between the European Union and Turkey
that said it's been seventeen me if I'm
not mistaken that by  example the issue
of returns from the return of migrants to
Turkey has not been resolved so
here you go anyway on
this track where is the
commission
really analyzing another more viable solution
than this thank you adalbert  thank you
very much for the figures I
may suggest getting back to you in writing
so that we can give you the
updated figures
but obviously we have them we are
monitoring the situation very closely
concerning the  declaration eu turkey
is indeed their full implementation
but tomorrow authorities for
us elsewhere there the side the
european union side continues
to implement this declaration
including by resettlement of
refugees from turkey in europe which
is part of  this this statement
this said maybe on the future of our
relationship with turkey or
cooperation on migration
maybe my colleagues would be
better placed to inform in detail
if you have any specific questions and that's
also a question that we want to take
on the side very easily cities
thank you very much to d'albert there
was another migration question here in
the press room
moyer thank you it's actually I think more
from a foreign affairs angle but
that's when  same migration I saw that
the high representative borel yesterday
spoke with the Iraqi foreign minister in
particular on this
question of the
sort of export of two people from baghdad
to minsk in belarus
and then pushed to the
lithuanian border i wanted to know if on these
talks he there let's say some
clarification on what is happening
i.e. who are these people
how they reach
boarding a plane to go to
belarus and what did
the iraqi minister possibly
promise or say about it is
he going to do something or or
let it be like that
thank you for your  question I will invite
nabil amr and sons-in-law here I know that
jack is interested today we
will close the migration chapter
after I will take and questions
jack
thank you for your who is sorry thank you for your
question
and
philippe indeed the  representative
spoke with the Iraqi foreign minister yesterday,
well unfortunately I cannot go
very far in the conversation since
it is a conversation that they had
within bilat  eral and that the
rep tweeted tweeted
about it all i can say is that
it was a conversation that was
important and that and that is
something that was that is that
is important to  the iraqis as
well as for the as for the
european union so i refer you to his to
his tweet that said what i can say
about the situation the
situation in general is that the
european union beyond  two of the high
representative who spoke with with with with
the minister with his Iraqi interpreter
you had you will have seen that the president of the
council that the president of the
commission that the project president borel
and that also the commissioner johan sonne
are on the subject and give
enormously important on the subject the delegation
also whether it is in baghdad where ankara
are in contact and we are also in
contact with certain
African nations and here I think that is
what I can say at this level thank you
nabila est  what  u there are other
questions only about migration we are
not going to open the foreign affairs chapter right away
for the moment we
are still on migration so
please keep your hands up
only 6.6 at mauzé market before the
race of toros that batman relational
supposed faults the next while a
b c to diest the parts situation of
the man the belarus m
and indicates a tax has dropped to stresa
tissot receive all advance that of
their slump others it will be necessary that
bordeaux leader bordeaux the kits
nvidia of the national leaders and s he
tell you that but it's true that that's
also the philosophy 20 dinars of
[Music]
orders remains we do this
singer
in total July 4 or August and 25 at
the pros of our 16 90  miles renshaw
and wonder if they no11 concerns about you
for pouget hx720 olympics have done
[Music]
210 and 220 which commission is in vst
that it is cured thing to and serve our
there pushes bugs to athlete  s base at the
lithuanians burgundy tel fifth in ca
d'albert
this break chained the pacs
of history by the levels of 2008 to
raise this commission is hot but
what is the week while wind
and tourism
[Music]
and that i want is this tgs at this time
that you go wherever you go crosses it
all wrong
that exactly what of a phase of works
of r
here no but it's  is still on the
migrants who therefore arrive at this
border lithuania belarusian is that
according to a first analysis it is estimated that
these are people who are
actually entitled to
asylum status or is it that on the contrary this
n  is not the case and in this hypothesis
is that for example the
Iraqi Minister of Foreign Affairs has
undertaken to take back the people who have
since left from Iraqi soil
adalbert yes I can start there in
any case with the first first  part
of the
question  situations differ one of
the fundamental principles of the right of asylum
in the european union is that any
decision must be taken
individually and it is the
responsibility of the national authorities
to look at the different situations
obviously a large part of these
people  will not be entitled to
international protection this is what
seems obvious in view of the
cutting composition that no one who arrives is
obviously in this context the question
of returns and routs to the rapid and
efficient will be central to the resolution
of this  situation thank you adalbert I
don't do I see no elements of
dreaming and it's once again thank you yes
and so if indeed we can't
know everything about what was discussed
between our efforts she is the
Iraqi minister this  that for example on this
issue the Iraqi minister made
some commitments or not at all
saying they left they left
didn't put there sorry to alert him
ph  ilippe what i can tell you is
that the discussion that took place the
conversation that there was between their
representative and the minister of foreign affairs
was done at the request of
joseph bourrel so and jpy so that  was
organized and it was there the opportunity
was to discuss discuss the situation
so want you l between lithuania and
belarus now what
happened is that the representative
asked the
iraqi foreign minister to  look into the
situation to see what is happening
and especially on the history of the young people
of emine appear at hasno good come
on minors who are not accompanied
so that's what I want to say
on the side of the  from the other side of the
Iraqi Minister unfortunately I
cannot speak for him but what I
can tell you is that this is
what the High Representative
asked the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Iraq to do
thank you  many i think adelbert
actors has a  added that currently also
on his side
yes just to say that beyond
the contacts at the political level taken at
their presentation as explained by
nabila we also have contacts
at the technical level with our partners
the case on this very
important question of  vultures and readmission
so this is something that is going to
continue very intensely in
the next few days and
weeks
thank you i see no three questions to
migrations now in the
online newsroom i have to get you up
but i am not  not sure if it's
on the subject of migration
please keep your hand up
only its six essays on
migration i think i'm
accepting more questions christiane ans
delivery man it's on migration both of these
subjects  different
ok I'll give you this part migration
christiane yes ok thank you yes in fact
it's a question for the city to what
he was at the podium it's only in
an interview  today published by the
daily newspaper el país sir on board she
was quite firm he says
that indeed there is a road of
the soul there is migration which is one
that has been established that they see
iraqis on board  in baghdad direction
minsk and from minsk they are taken to
the border by coach so I am
quite perplexed on the fact that while
we have relations and support with
the rate but hush borel did not
ask the Iraqi ministry  to
ensure that these flights do not take off
with candidates for Iraqi migration
to Minsk and that this would
effectively avoid all the problems that
will arise afterwards to have
these Iraqis who arrived
illegally in Lithuania repatriated will not make them
pray that the  lithuania towards the rules nor
his party etc
I have the impression that we are beating
around the bush while Mr. Bord
she clearly identifies the problem
he raised it in this interview he says
that indeed there is and adalbe  rt
repeated there is an exploitation of the
problems of migrants that they
only that belarus the authorities
of belarus are using migrants as a
response to the sanctions of the european union
we can not be clearer by
exposing the problem so i don't  ca
n't understand why we ca
n't solve them
at the start either, that is to say with the country of
departure which is ugly rock and the
Iraqi authorities who could
control their airports for
me Christian I don't know if it was  a
question what can i say no no
but i see what you mean i did
not say that mr borel was
not clear i just said what
mr morel what i can say at this
stage of  this platform is that the high
representative asked and for
this reason called the myth sens the
Iraqi foreign minister to
ask him for clarifications on the subject
so I do not see what is
beating around the bush thank you  nabi  there we
are still on migration I'm
sorry then we're going to change the subject
oliver and you say that's our subject
zhaxi so I'm going to ask ray already I
'm sorry nabila if you can yes
go back to costs for the
foreign affairs question because  jack said
he's in progress and so we're going to
take his question right away and
then we'll go back to other questions
for nabila jack
[Music]
we must have to in d'establishment of de
alex pattern maker of countries for taking
reciprocity our match to all
for example oceania black cat's
eye to the point of flirting
signage
[Music]
how consider you offers two
formulas perez california
ring oceania no one pressure  non online so
happy to turn over
china imagine de rugby fort nabila
[Music]
five soldiers
olliver folio queen which are not so
what i can do it is to be like you know
that thing you do not have will leave me
sim sim sim usim te  nnis li challenger
we have china and negotiating partner is
an economic school born competitor
test this system is systematic
system i drive opinion when it comes to
position as its commitment china
we try to view invests workforce 40
relationship with the value of interest
so when it comes  to disk a thing as well
as the man who is we don't live
from talking to
china  hagai levi the battle
of nancy allan lines may 5.11 to 6 a
document paper and solutions
major of asia species to negotiate the
protocol stanley tucci good faith and
we have a good faith
boostedge cooperation is next and black wiland
orchestra consult an agent  comedy
we also on line of fixed packages is
radical rideout by fire and sean hoare
denis to have booster vaccine doses attack boost
us vaccines am yes to
march 20 2  010 veninov booster rexie of the six
currencies swap and policies we booster
finally in short concludes manufacture of an
effective vaccine there is the law continues to
live on credit sights of factors against
110.15 yen commission it is a strong axis
audience booster at  to drive the
ring have driven the commission
globus think done last year we be
long
yes apart kovacs a tweet with cynicism
become sun sf drops against respond
to take this waltz y opinion good idea
so right now
a release
[Music
] basically it september  any check to
locate his two accomplices pect the ladies
in white polka dots
5th round two weeks hugo de president
still remained the same
stay tuned admistration solidarity no
we asked for an audience via email
and craft stand by